hey you guys flickers of fear time and
as i am want to do on this show uh every
now and then i like to throw in a yellow
movie because you guys know how much i
like those and this is another one of
those times so this was one this was
actually one that i had not uh seen
before prior to watching it for this
review but it was one that i'd always
been really interested in seeing because
it was directed by emilio moralia the
same guy who did the night evelyn came
out of the grave uh which i reviewed
previously and it came out like the year
before this now he really didn't make a
lot of movies as a director i kind of
feel like he was more like a crew guy
and you know he did other he he played
other roles i think he only directed
like maybe six movies and only two of
them were giallo movies but i have to
say that these two were actually a
couple of my favorite ones and it's
amazing to me that it took me so long to
see this one which is his second one um
because as much as i loved the night
evelyn came out of the grave i actually
think this one is a big step forward and
i think this one is actually a lot
better in the sense that it has kind of
the same vibe or the same kind of like
crossover tone that he got with the
first one but i just think that would it
it was like better constructed and it
was better shot and it just seemed like
it had a bigger budget which i guess it
did because what ended up happening uh
with that was that i guess like the
night evelyn came out of the grave was
an unexpected success
and so he was kind of convinced to do
another giallo film it's like i said
he's done some other movies but
most of them were not uh giallo films he
only made two like that so this one is
called the red queen kill seven times it
has a [ __ ] ton of other titles as most
italian films do none of them were
really i think that was i think in some
points when it was released in the us it
might have been called blood feast and
i'm like no not that blood feast like
the herschel gordon lewis one completely
different movie but it had like a bunch
of other titles too none of which i can
like remember at the moment but the red
queen killed seven times is a great
title and pretty much
uh other than like it doesn't have an
animal in the title but it does have a
number in the title so i will give it
that uh so it is kind of like a really
classic like giallo sort of title
now much like uh the night evelyn came
out of the grave this this second movie
has a lot of things in common with it
one of which is that one of the main
characters is named evelyn even though
they're not you know they're not the
same character uh this movie also has
marina malfati in it
uh who was also in the first one and it
also has this kind of combining of
giallo and the gothic genres in the
sense that you have like a creepy castle
like a family curse
uh somebody named evelyn that may or may
not have come back from the grave like
to exact revenge on their killer so
it's similar but then
in a lot of ways like i feel like it's
not all that similar because this one i
kind of feel like even though it does
have the whole geologothic uh you know
crossover kind of thing going on just
like the other one did
this one
i don't want to say it's
less sleazy because it is still kind of
sleazy but it's sleazy in a classy way
there's like not because remember when i
was talking about the night evelyn came
out of the grave it had kind of like an
s m kind of uh vibe to it too this one
doesn't really have that this one
actually has more of a blood and black
lace like mario baba kind of thing
because a lot of it is kind of like set
in a fashion house like in the fashion
world which i guess a lot of uh several
jello wear after after uh blood and
black lace came out because you know
it's just such a great way to
uh show a bunch of scantily clad models
uh show a bunch of like really cool like
jet set locations and a lot of like
really mod up to the minute fashions and
stuff like that so you can see why that
was kind of like a pretty common trope
and indeed it is a trope in this one as
well so i kind of like the balance
between
there being this kind of like really
really creepy old castle with dungeons
and
torches and [ __ ] and bats and [ __ ] like
that but then kind of
uh contrasted against this really super
modern uh you know fashion house type
situation so uh this is actually it's an
italian german co-production and i
believe it was uh shot in germany uh
because all the signs are german all the
names are in german even though it
seemed like most of the actors were
italian the version that i watched uh
which is on 2b this used to be on
shutter i don't know if it still is and
it's on amazon prime but i think you
have to pay 2.99 or 3.99 it's on 2b for
free and the version that's on 2b
is in italian with english subtitles but
as i said it's not
it's still dubbed they all were it just
depends on what language they were
dubbed into i do feel like when they
release them in the us usually they dub
them into english but this one was
actually dubbed into italian
because that's what most of the actors
were and uh you know then it was uh you
know uh subtitled in english so that's
the version that's on 2b and i'm sure
that's probably the most uh available
version
you know for whatever streaming service
i think this also might have come out i
think it came out on a nice blu-ray and
i think there's also maybe a special
edition blu-ray or maybe a special
edition dvd like a while back that i'm
thinking of that uh had this movie and
the night evelyn came out of the grave
like as a double feature which i thought
was kind of neat because like i said
these are all these are almost kind of
like two
sister films even though they have a lot
of elements in common even though
they're they're a lot different but they
do have kind of like a lot of
similarities as well it's funny because
i'd seen the night evelyn came out of
the grave like probably two or three
times when i was growing up but for
whatever reason i had never got around
to seeing this one and then like when i
watched this one i was kind of like oh
you know what i think this one's like
actually a lot better so
you know just goes to show and you know
from just kind of a cursory reading of a
bunch of different reviews and stuff it
really does seem like this is a very
well regarded entry into into the sub
genre what you know a lot of people
really seem to like this one and a lot
of people really do seem to
you know think it was kind of a shame
that emilio morelia didn't make more
gela movies because these two that he
made were actually really good
so what you have in this one is you have
there's kind of like a scene at the
beginning where there's two little girls
who are sisters even though they don't
look anything alike
one of them is named kitty and one of
them is named evelyn
now they uh apparently really really
[ __ ] hate each other so they're just
like they're both they're about the same
age they're probably like eight or nine
or something like that
and uh so they're always fighting and
you know what evelyn's always like
stealing kitty's doll and so they're all
having this thing so they live in this
big huge uh mansion this big it's a
castle essentially is what it is and
they live with their grandfather no one
ever says like what the parent what
happened to the parents or anything like
that so they live there they're fighting
all the time they go in their poor
grandfather who is played by a german
actor um i can't remember what his name
is but he was the same guy that played i
mean he was in a [ __ ] ton of movies like
going back to the 20s because i looked
up his wikipedia page
but uh horror fans will probably
recognize him as carl from the exorcist
like the servant in the household and he
was also the witch expert in suspiria so
there's that but like i said he was in a
huge huge number of movies going all the
like decades and decades back his first
movie was actually in 1924 and that kind
of like blew my mind but yeah so he
plays the grandfather in this
and he
very hilariously tries to get these two
little sisters to stop fighting with one
another
by telling them about this family legend
family curse so in granddad's study uh
which apparently the little girls have
never noticed this i i guess they've
noticed the painting because they said
it was before but he has this big huge
like full-length painting
of
this woman like in a black dress and
then there's a woman in a white dress
like behind her like totally stabbing
her right so granddad tells them about
the family curse or the family legend or
whatever you want to call it where what
ended up happening was way back i think
it was in the 1600s maybe or i don't
know but there was kind of this whole
uh there's there's this legend that like
there's two sisters in this family
and
one of them like and they've hate each
other one of them's the red queen and
one of them is the black queen so they
hate each other and then one of them got
married and the other one got jealous so
what ends up happening is that the black
queen kills the red queen the red queen
comes back from the dead
and kills
six people and then kills the red queen
like her sister the one that had killed
her so apparently every hundred years
this curse repeats itself but always
with two sisters
in this family so you know is don't
think about it too hard because
obviously you know every hundred years
are there really gonna be like two
sisters what if there's brothers or what
if it's a brother and a sister what if
there's not two sisters like when the
curse time comes around like i said
don't think about it too much but it's
just a legend that grandpa says it's you
know it's not real it didn't happen so
uh you know so the girls are like oh
when's the next hundred years gonna be
up and he's like oh 1972 which is 14
years in the future
so uh obviously at that point we jump
forward to 1972 which is contemporary
when the uh for when the movie was made
and uh the girls have all grown up well
okay so so at least one of the girls has
grown up
uh kitty has grown up she's actually
played by the gorgeous barbara boucher
and she is working as a fashion
photographer at a you know kind of
swanky fashion house called spring with
an e at the end like german
and uh evelyn is kind of nowhere to be
seen there's also another sister
francisca francisca and he's played by
marina malfati and they actually don't
really say where the hell she came from
because she was not mentioned in the
flashback when the you know when the
girls were little so i don't know where
this girl came from but whatever so uh
but she's the she's the older sister i
guess so the first thing that happens is
that the grandpa who is still alive uh i
guess fran uh francisca has been taking
care of him because
uh kitty has moved away
and we're led to believe at least at
first that evelyn has gone to america
and hasn't like been communicating with
the family anymore so francisca's been
taking care of the grandfather in his
old age
but then one night he's laying in bed
and he wakes up and he sees what appears
to be a woman in a red cloak coming at
him with a knife now this figure uh does
not stab him but he uh dies a fright he
has a heart attack and uh subsequently
the
red cloaked figure runs off laughing
maniacally like kind of like a witch or
whatever now after the grandfather dies
obviously there's some stuff with the
inheritance because he was like rich as
[ __ ] like i said he's got a castle and
he's got like hunting grounds and he's
got all this all that stuff so after the
grandfather dies everybody gathers for
you know the reading of the will
and uh obviously evelyn is not there
because like i said uh everyone says oh
she's gone to america we don't know
where she's at like we can't get hold of
her blah blah blah
and it turns out like the grandfather
what he does though was he was kind of
clever because i guess
he sort of foresaw that he was going to
drop dead during the year when the
100-year curse was supposed to happen
like with two sisters killing each other
so basically what he did was he's like
well here's what's gonna happen with the
will however um i wrote all the
instructions like in this letter and
y'all are not allowed to open this
letter until a year from now until the
100 year curse has passed and hopefully
all of the curse stuff will be sorted
out by then then we can kind of
distribute the money so everybody thinks
they were going to get like the money
and they don't get the monies like they
have to wait like another year
someone's kind of bummed out about that
now you find out like pretty early on in
the story like probably probably in the
first 15 20 minutes like not too long i
think after the will has been read
that evelyn even though um everybody has
been told that she has gone to america
and is just saying you know [ __ ] my
family i don't talk to them anymore
actually evelyn is dead turns out we're
shown in a flashback which i don't think
they ever say how long ago it was it
couldn't have been that long ago because
nobody looks kind of the same i think it
was like six months or a year or
something like that
what ended up happening was that kitty
and evelyn were having a cat fight like
on the front lawn of the castle just
like they used to do when they were kids
like you [ __ ] farmer and they're like
pulling each other's hair and stuff
and kitty accidentally like knocks her
into this big stone pillar thing and
then she falls into the moat so kitty's
like oh [ __ ] you know like i
accidentally killed my sister for to
their credit i guess the older sister
francesca francesca and her
husband i guess that's her husband his
name's harold i think and uh they see
they kind of see it happen and she's
like look it was an accident we were
just kind of fighting and which it was
uh and then they were like okay well
it's fine you don't want to get in
trouble we don't want anything to get
involved we'll just like stick her down
in the crypt or whatever they kind of
like hide her down in the dungeon
they're like just we won't tell anybody
we'll just tell her we took off for
america we don't know where she went
we'll just all keep mom about it and
it'll be fine so that's essentially what
they do so pretty much the family like
kitty and francesca and harold know that
evelyn is dead but nobody else knows
that
however
something that francesca tells to uh
kitty is that hey you know before uh our
grandpa died
he said that he had seen the red queen
or he had seen like this woman like uh
running through the yard like with a red
cloak on and said that he heard her
laughing and francesca says and i also
heard her
so at this point kitty starts kind of
like freaking out because she's kind of
like well you know what if it's the
curse what if evelyn she's like i know
evelyn's dead right and they even go
down into the dungeon and they look in
the little crypt or the cell or whatever
where they stuffed her and yep she's
still there she's still dead so it's
like well what the [ __ ] going on like
you know somebody's like running around
and maybe she is back from the dead
maybe she's a ghost or whatever so as
the movie goes on
more and more people turn up dead most
of whom have to do with the fashion
house where kitty works
um like one guy the guy that's like the
managing director or whatever um he ends
up getting killed like stabbed to death
in a park when where he's out like
trolling for prostitutes with with this
other woman that works there i guess
she's a model and her name's lulu and
she's played by sybil danning actually
in uh in a pretty uh early role of hers
and i guess his thing i think his name's
hans and his thing is that he him and
lulu
go out to the park and like pick up
prostitutes like for threesomes that's
like his thing
and so they're out doing that but then
while she's out kind of like going and
getting the prostitute
like somebody comes like a woman in a
red cloak comes and stabs him to death
and like leaves him by the car and then
like other people turn up dead too so
it's kind of like this whole situation
where
just like in most giallo movies you kind
of feel like everybody has a reason
uh for killing somebody and everybody is
a suspect and then there's this other
dude martin
who actually was the guy underneath uh
hans and he gets his job like after he
dies and he also happens to be sleeping
with kitty
so
it's almost like they're setting him up
to be a red herring and actually the
police
think that he may have uh killed some of
the people because it turns out later on
that one of the people who ends up dead
is his wife who is in like a mental
institution and when he goes to visit
her one day his wife says to him says
evelyn's name and says yeah evelyn comes
to visit me every night and we run
around outside the gate like in the
forest and
she's going to give me a knife to kill
you with and all this other kind of
stuff and he doesn't know how seriously
to take this because he's like well
she's having hallucinations because of
the drugs and everything like that but
then it turns out that like she does
actually try to get out of the night the
next night like after he visits her and
she tries to climb over the fence and
this woman in a red cloak comes there
gives her the knife and then when she's
like climbing over the fence like she
the other woman like cuts the ladder so
that she falls and like the spike of the
fence like goes up through her chin in
like a really gory that's probably like
one of the best scenes in the movie it's
just like this really really gory kind
of [ __ ] scene so because martin's
boss is killed and because martin's wife
gets killed so martin obviously and like
everybody else is sort of in the same
kind of circles
so everybody kind of thinks well he was
the one that had the motive to do all
that kind of stuff and then there's all
these other people too that are also
doing sketchy [ __ ] like there's a woman
named rosemary who also works at the
fashion house and she seems to have like
some shady shifty kind of stuff going on
but you're not really sure what there's
this dude named peter who's like a drug
addict and he seems to know or at some
point figures out
that evelyn is actually dead and that
kitty was the one that killed her so
basically he's been blackmailing kitty
and at one point later on in the movie
this was a little alarming there's
actually he comes to her house and takes
a bunch of money again and then he just
essentially like rapes her they don't
they show it like
obviously they kind of show like the
beginning of it but then they just like
cut away to the aftermath and she's just
and kitty is just like laying there like
all there's like blood on the carpet and
then she's her like her eye makeup is
all [ __ ] up and everything and she's
just all like they're naked and freaking
out and then like they don't mention it
again it was just like a really weird
because like i'm watching it going that
was uh upsettingly random but yeah i'm
not really sure like what the [ __ ] was
going on with that but yeah so so like i
said there's all there's kind of all
these
convoluted plots and for a long time i
was kind of like well they were setting
it up to be martin so much that i was
like okay that can't be him because the
cops think it's him and that's not
usually the way it works because
sometimes in these
in jala movies there is a trope where
sometimes it's like oh there's like whoa
the killer could be a woman um but then
sometimes it's a man dressed as a woman
or there's some other [ __ ] going on this
one they make it pretty clear from the
beginning
that the killer is actually a woman
they do kind of make a stop to the fact
well martin could just be wearing a wig
and a red cloak or whatever but when you
see the killer running around that
definitely does look like a woman it
looks like a woman's hands it looks like
the way she runs you can kind of see the
side of her profile and it does actually
look like a woman and also everybody
like every time somebody gets killed uh
when she runs away she laughs and it's
like a woman's laugh
so even though the cops think that it's
martin because of because he's the one
that had the motive for at least two of
the murders and he doesn't have a super
good alibi or they think that his alibi
is too perfect he engineered it like to
be like that so you pretty much know
it's not him
now i will admit that even though
i suspected
i suspected like who was behind the
stuff but i didn't actually know like
what
the plot was gonna come out like because
much like the night evelyn came out of
the grave if anything this movie the
plot of this one like the scheme behind
it is like way more complicated and like
for a second i'm watching it going wait
what i don't
you know what i mean it was that kind of
thing so what ends up let me see if i
can uh if i can explain this because
like i said i've only seen it once and i
only seen it like a couple hours ago so
i'm trying to figure out like okay so
kitty did actually okay she didn't
actually kill evelyn but she thought she
did so they had the fight it was an
accident she accidentally knocked her
into a thing just like you saw on the
flashback kit and uh evelyn falls into
the moat
however what kitty didn't know was that
she kind of got hurted away by francesco
francesca or whatever being like okay
we'll we'll cover this whole thing up
but what she didn't know was that after
she had kind of turned away and was
freaking out and everything evelyn woke
back up she wasn't dead
um but then francesca decided just on
the spur of the moment mind you that
it's like well since she's already
laying in there and kitty already thinks
she's dead
maybe um i could bump her off and get
more of the inheritance after uh
granddad croaks so she basically she's
straight up she like is like she's gonna
pull her out of the moat and then she's
like straight up takes her head and
starts like whacking it on the side of
the [ __ ] and i was i legit like when
i saw that scene i was like damn it was
like really uh really brutal but yeah so
she so evelyn is actually dead however
we find out later on that evelyn who
we've thought was evelyn this
dark-haired girl this whole time um you
know in the whole like even the cops
have the whole like identique drawing
that looks like her and all this other
kind of stuff which is why kitty is kind
of like losing her mind she's like dude
my sister's back from the dead this is
like freaking me out so there's that
whole thing so for a while you're not
really sure if it's going to go a
supernatural direction giallo movies
usually don't um usually they have
some kind of natural rational
explanation as batshit and convoluted as
it might be
but you never know because there have
been a couple i was thinking uh
specifically of perfume of the lady in
black i think that i'm pretty sure that
had like a supernatural angle to it too
so some of them do have that but it's
pretty rare usually
usually there's like a rational
explanation but it's usually like crazy
like it's not usually anything that
would happen in real life but uh but yes
so yeah so what you find out is that
evelyn
you know the girl that you thought was
evil and the dark haired girl from the
flashback did actually die
but what you find out is that she was
actually not
kitty's biological sister she was just
some orphan
that the grandad had adopted way back
when
to somehow try to circumvent the curse
because maybe he thought well it won't
it you know the curse won't play out if
they're not biologically related so
there was that whole thing however there
was another sister who was supposed to
be evelyn i don't know like if she knew
or i don't know this is like really
complicated and that sister ended up
being
rosemary
now
now was she really the sister okay what
ended up happening was that francesca
who was the older sister
she she told rosemary who also worked at
the fashion house
that she was actually evelyn that she
was actually related to kitty that she
was the actual missing sister whether
that's true or not i don't really
remember because like i said this is a
very complicated plot
so she not only told her that and she's
like well if you help me bump off all
the other family members then we'll get
the like the big inheritance and we'll
split it but she also started plying her
with drugs
through
uh peter the scuzzy guy that raped kitty
earlier on in the movie uh peter also
ends up getting killed by the by the red
queen pushing him out the car window and
like just dragging him alongside the car
so that was like some nice variety there
from uh you know the usual jello
stabbings couple people get shot in this
one too now that i'm thinking about it
so she basically like applied the woman
with drugs and then made her
wear the red cloak and wear this like
creepy
mask that looks kind of like a real face
but not quite it was very uncanny valley
so that she would look like so that when
people saw her she would look like
evelyn and that would freak kitty out
and blah blah so she's like well
basically we have to do this curse um
and we have to kill six people and
they're trying to like pin it on other
people so they're killing certain people
to make to you know kind of like pin it
on others but what ended up happening
with that was that they kind of like the
whole plot got discovered by martin and
also by herbert who was actually
francesca's husband i think
and francesca like he overhears her
saying something about what a [ __ ] he
was or something like that because he
had like a like a lame leg or whatever
and so he ends up just straight up
straight up shooting her ass and uh
before she dies though she actually
stabs martin but i guess martin lives
everybody else [ __ ] dies though
herbert dies everybody dies but since
kitty
who actually was like i said innocent
the whole time yes she did accidentally
kill her sister she didn't mean to kill
her sister they were just like fighting
and kind of like scuffling around and it
just happened like they covered them
they covered the death up which
obviously is not good but she didn't do
anything bad otherwise uh so her and
martin ended up even though martin got
stabbed like i said he did survive and
they end up living happily ever after
and everybody else basically got killed
and kitty since
there's no more
uh you know francesca got killed
rosemary got killed everybody got killed
so kitty's the only one left to like
inherit all this stuff so it was like a
win-win but you know what i mean so yeah
like i was saying i can't believe it
took me this long to
see this giallo movie because especially
because i liked the night evelyn came
out of the grave so much and i knew that
he had uh that emilio morelia had done
this other one and i was just like man i
really need to you know and that seemed
to have like really good reviews and
stuff and i was just kind of like man i
really need to get around to that one of
these days and i ended up liking it a
lot better like it's really like i said
the plot is very very complicated um you
really have to like pay attention to
everyone's motivations and stuff but
the plot is actually really well
constructed it actually does make sense
um like i said it's bat [ __ ] crazy like
this this convoluted plot um it's
something that you would never get away
with in real life but that's just par
for the course like for jello movies um
and i like that it had
that that same kind of like gothic flair
to it
um but it also had like a really modern
like a very mod 70s kind of look to it
oh also fun fact i was watching it in
one of the was it lulu's apartment or
martin's apartment but there's a couple
scenes in that apartment and i'm looking
at that apartment going god damn it that
[ __ ]
wallpaper and that couch is so goddamn
familiar i'm like where the hell have i
seen that i was like that must have been
in another movie and uh sure enough when
i looked it up it was the same apartment
set that they had used for the strange
vice of mrs ward because i was like i
knew i'd seen that ugly ass wallpaper
somewhere like that stripy ass wallpaper
but yeah it's like all the furniture and
stuff like that is just so [ __ ] mod
but like i said it's cool because
it's really really contrasted against
this super god like hammer horror
castle with like [ __ ] dungeons and
and i love that there's like bats flying
around like in the crypts and everything
and everyone's just kind of like yeah
bats and they're real bats too it looks
like it doesn't look like that little
plastic like on a string or anything um
it looks like real bats and all the
actors are just kind of like yeah bats
whatever um although there's like tons
of rats and stuff too and there's
actually a great scene toward the end
where um where francesca is trying to
kill kitty
and she essentially like floods the you
know she's also killed uh rosemary
because she was the only other person
that knew about her plot or this this
crazy plot that she had cooked up so
she's actually trying to flood
the dungeons like the crypt area or
whatever and there's this great scene
where there's like a water pipe and all
these rats like come out of this water
pipe like oh [ __ ] here comes the water
and then like the room starts filling up
and like she's gonna drown and stuff and
it's just like it's a really really
great uh very very gothic and it's like
really cool but yeah i really like that
juxtaposition you didn't see that a lot
i don't think like um you know i finally
feel like giallo movies usually
were very like contemporary they were
like contemporary crime thrillers so
it's a little unusual to see one with
like really like old-school gothic
elements like this and i really liked
that
that juxtaposition um also oh i have to
note too not only that ugly-ass
wallpaper that was in that apartment but
also during one scene i think it was
rosemary wears
legitimately the most ridiculous
pair of glasses i've ever seen and i'm
and i'm counting elton john's like big
sparkly star glasses and stuff because
obviously he was wearing those like to
be glam and stuff these were actually i
guess supposed to be like actual
legitimate fashionable
glasses
and they are just
massive they're massive and they're like
pentagon shaped or something or hexagon
shaped they're just they're so big they
take up like half the poor woman's face
but it's just kind of it's it's crazy
but uh but yeah so just like in most
examples of the genre there's it's not
it's kind of gory i will say it's like
it's it's pretty bloody it's pretty
violent not as gory as some that i've
seen and not as like over the top as you
know like dario argento or something but
you know particularly the couple scenes
where like the one scene where
martin's wife gets like impaled on the
spike like on the
fence and it's uh you know that's really
bloody and there's like a lot of
stabbings and [ __ ] like that there's a
really great kind of like dreamlike
sequence where the red queen is like
running down this hall in slow motion
like with the cloak coming out and it's
like really really cool looking and it's
kind of like a weird dream sequence
that's really awesome and uh you know
and i was gonna say too that that of
that scene where um
where francesca is killing evelyn by
like just banging her head on the side
of the concrete mode or whatever and
that's like pretty [ __ ] up so that so
there's all kind of like gore in this
and like i said peter getting dragged to
death by you know on the side of the car
that was kind of like a nice change so
you got that there's also like your kind
of uh requisite sort of sleaze uh lots
and lots of nudity not not male nudity
unfortunately but uh
if you're into that but lots and lots of
female duty lots and lots of boobies uh
lots of there's kind of a weird rape
scene it's not super long but
i'm not really sure why it was there
because it wasn't really brought up
again which i thought was very strange
it's just kind of like inserted randomly
so uh yeah that was a little weird but
yeah you know so like a lot of models
and fashion shoots and crazy
you know early 70s fashions and gorgeous
locations like i said this was actually
shot in germany i think they shot some
of it in monaco too now that i'm
thinking about it but uh you know so
it's almost kind of like a amazing like
travel log of early 70s europe like all
these awesome kind of locations and then
all these kind of
ridiculously beautiful women in these
like ridiculously 70s fashions and
ridiculous glasses and stuff like that
but yeah this one
uh i really really like this one a lot
this is actually one of the best ones
that i've ever seen
and i really enjoyed it you know like i
said the plot's convoluted but you can
still follow it if you're paying
attention and it's paced really well um
it doesn't drag like because some of
them do they have like long periods
where stuff but this one moves along at
a pretty good clip i think it's like an
hour and 40 minutes or something like
that and there's always something going
on so there's always like a murder going
on or some kind of you know or some kind
of nudity or some kind of something so
it never gets boring it always like
moves along really quickly but yeah this
is actually a really really good example
of the genre so if you haven't seen this
one uh you definitely should check it
out because like i said it's i feel like
maybe maybe not a lot of people like
bring this one up as much as some of the
kind of bigger better known ones in the
genre and this is definitely one that's
worth watching and like i said it's kind
of a shame that emilio morelia didn't
make more gela movies because the two
that he made were pretty pretty damn
good um but yeah this is actually on 2b
for free if you want to watch it i think
the night evelyn came out of the grave
might be on to be for free as well i
think it's also on shutter so you might
want to check there first so you don't
have to watch commercials but to be
actually now that i'm good now that i'm
mentioning it
actually has a pretty decent selection
of geolo movies so if you're just kind
of getting into the genre i mean there's
it they don't have like most of the kind
of top tier ones but they do have kind
of a lot of the b squad uh you know the
ones that are just to tear down from
like dario argento or whatever all they
then they think i think they have a
couple dario argento ones on there too i
think the cat of nine tails might be on
there and a couple other ones but yeah
so uh definitely check this one out if
you're into italian horror at all
because this was a really really good
one and uh if you've seen it let me know
what you uh thought about it in the
comments and that will do it for this
flickers of fear i will see you guys on
the next one bye